what is up everybody axel here for anime
uproar and as you know if i'm here that
means we're going to have another
jiu jitsu kaizen video today i will be
discussing
everything about my personal favorite
character in jiu-jitsu kaizen
ali toto while there are a ton of
interesting and amazing people in this
series
i've always just thought that toto's
personality really just helped him shine
he takes all of the best and funniest
parts of characters like gojo
and ramps it up to 11 while also being
surprisingly mature when he wants to be
when it comes to funny characters
powerful characters and dudes so ripped
you could grate cheese on their abs
toto really is a living trifecta in jiu
jitsu kaizen
so obviously we have to talk about him
before we do though if you end up
enjoying this video and want to see more
jiu jitsu kaizen content
on this channel be sure to leave a like
and maybe consider leaving a comment
with who you'd like to see me talk about
next
it will only take a second but it is a
huge help for the channel
and hey if you haven't subscribed to
anime uproar make this the video that
you do by clicking on that bell and
selecting all notifications
you can also follow anime upload on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar or
you can follow myself
at excellionyt of course this video will
contain jujutsu kaizen manga spoilers so
proceed with caution
you have been warned so there's a few
points we need to talk about when it
comes to toto
first of all who he is his personality
and how he views the world and people
around him
and second his abilities and role in the
story
if i had to describe toto in one word it
would probably be
passionate he gives his all in every
facet of his life
and he wants to see others doing the
same just on a design standpoint you
might even consider this in terms of his
body
with toto easily being the most muscular
character in the series at this point
i guess except for panda sometimes but
i'm not sure if that really counts in
this situation or not but it could be
assumed that he puts a ton of time
and effort into himself and his health
to ensure that he gets the most out of
life
the muscles also act as a way to help
him stand out in the series
allowing him to literally feel larger
than life
when you compare him to any character
around him and all of that
ties in perfectly to the core of his
character to toto it's important that
everyone be passionate about their lives
and that means that you should be
exciting and honest
we see this best in his first
interactions with both megumi
and itadori in which are probably some
of my favorite moments in the entire
first season
in each case we see this behemoth of a
man getting ready for
battle looking his opponents in the eye
and in the most
deadpan and serious way possible asking
what kind of women do you like
it is goddamn hilarious i mean
just look at this panel here when he
first approaches megumi he says that
he'll decide whether to beat him half to
death or not based on his answer
and that might seem a little bit extreme
but this is a question that's very
important to toto
we later find out that when toto was
younger he would often get in fights
with older guys who he felt were mocking
him however
he was simply so much stronger that they
weren't any fun to fight against
and he would just become bored one day
after beating up one of these boring
older guys he was approached by yuki
tsukumo who asked him the same question
and would eventually go on to become his
mentor
toto believes that this question is the
ultimate test of a man's character
if you like boring girls then you
probably are boring yourself
and he will hate you for it for example
megami explains he doesn't really have a
preference
as long as the girl is compassionate
then they're probably his
type a very wholesome probably socially
correct answer
however it is admittedly kinda boring
and toto seems to agree that it's boring
so he
immediately clotheslines megumi suplexes
him and quite literally drags him
through a school and beats him
constantly until they're cut off by toge
and panda on the other hand when he asks
itadori what kind of women he likes
and itadori has the exact same taste in
women toto does
toto immediately goes into this
dreamlike state where he imagines an
entire high school life with itadore
where they became
best friends support each other's love
lives and all of that some might say
this is psychotic
but i say probably yeah this can
initially give a pretty weird view of
toto honestly i know at the very least
when i first saw him blasting megami
through a school
i thought he was kind of this berserker
who was all about fighting
and kind of a muscle head however as
soon as he meets someone like itadori
who he actually gets along with
he becomes more well spoken and is
almost philosophical we especially see
this when he takes up the mantle of
being itadore's mentor
best friendo and braza going on to teach
him how to better use his cursed energy
and helping him to master the black
flash
he explains how cursed energy is often
seen as this flowing thing from one body
part to another
but it doesn't work like that we don't
get angry from our heads
and then it spreads to the rest of our
body and we don't think with our
stomachs
we exist as one body and one soul in its
entirety
a surprisingly beautiful mental image
given by this
big muscly gorilla once itadori actually
begins picking up on this mentality that
toto is explaining
toto explains that there's no more need
for talking and that he will guide and
teach ithdory through their fight
together and won't be holding back
anymore
i think that really sums up how toto
interacts with those around him
he is all or nothing he's either
disgusted with their boringness
or sudo adopts them as a brother
immediately becoming
attached to them and while we're on the
topic of toto's big question
i actually got a few friends of the
channel together to see what they think
to
toto's very philosophical question mr
414
what kind of women are you into women um
you asked me you asked me this while my
fiance is here this is the real uh
ginger giant boobers the 2d uh is
obvious
for me curry me so anything like that
would be the one what's going on tyler
uh quick question what kind of women are
you into
yeah i was about to do the total answer
i'm like nah let's answer genuinely
are you ready my taste in women is for
really there is none it's just
i just like women in general all women
are beautiful i love all my queens
the two spookster himself got a quick
question for you
very important what kind of women do you
like well just say that
cowgirls there you go that's my i'm into
cowgirls that's all i got evenido thank
you
so much for calling me uh in that one
nux video
returning the favor what kind of women
are you into um
the ones with big asses and long legs
is this for a video oh gee as a very
serious uh
very scientific man what kind of women
do you like
only the thickest why here why why here
what are we doing here dakota i'm just
going to assume that for you
every kind of woman is fine yes that's
there okay thank you
kevin yo we have the same taste in women
please explain it to the people
uh blue haired girls with birds all
right i couldn't get a hold of animak
but it's probably gonna be like any
woman from black clover or my hero
academia
and then thick milfs well i guess at
least some of them passed
this all-out attitude extends to toto's
other hobbies as well
and speaking of hobbies he has a pretty
interesting one
toto loves idols and handshake events
and as someone who lived in japan for a
year and had a friend who was
very into them and would try to get me
to go to them i gotta say i never really
saw the appeal
of it that said i do know someone that
we just talked to
who i think could shed some light on the
topic so let's call dakota back
hello um again so i do have a very
serious
and uh difficult question for you can
you please explain why people
like uh yourself would be interested in
handshake events idols or v tubers
okay so i would just say that like
handshake events and personal events
is something that anime fans and or fans
of somebody in general as it would be
important because it's a personal
connection that you actually get to draw
with the actual
actor or singer or performer or whatever
else it's really important as a
fan of somebody to be able to say things
that you think are meaningful to them
and then for them
to be able to reassure you on your your
supports and that everything that you do
means something it's just
it's a nice heartwarming wonderful
interaction that you get to have with
something that you thought was out of
reach but it really is just right there
honestly it's a lot less perfect than
you think oh that was weird anyways
that more or less sums up toto as a
person so let's move on to his abilities
he has a few which are shared between
many jiu-jitsu sorcerers for example
he can make simple domains to disrupt or
counter curse techniques
and he is one of the few people that
we've seen actually able to use black
flash an ability which is essentially
like getting into the zone
and allows for much stronger attacks
than normal this puts him in a pretty
small group along with characters like
nanami itadori nobara mahito and of
course
gojo i'm sure there are plenty of other
sorcerers who have been able to do this
as well
but still this is something that's
definitely worth noting
of course when you think of toto you
aren't exactly jumping to either of
those abilities
you instead probably think of his
signature innate curse technique
boogie woogie which what a fantastic
name
this ability allows toto to swap his
location with another person
whenever he claps his hands this
description is actually toto's greatest
strength
as while he might give this explanation
to his opponents when he first meets
them
this isn't exactly how that works while
toto
is able to swap places with someone else
he can also swap with any object or
being
in that area not really being limited to
people
furthermore he can also swap the
location of two other things as well
so for example in his fight with itadore
against taunami
he could swap both his location with
hanumi or he could swap hanami with
itadori
this creates a near limitless and
impossible to predict amount of options
that allows toto to completely disorient
and overwhelm his opponents
they will never know where the opponent
will come from or where they will go to
and they don't even know where they
themselves will be sent or what they'll
be looking
towards when they get there and when you
couple this with the false explanations
that total can often lead a fight with
as well as toto's insane strength speed
and battle experience
it is easy to see how he can confuse and
absolutely dominate his enemies
even the idea of clapping is a little
looser than you might expect
as he's able to clap with other people's
hands as well as he did with majito
it leaves the question of if slapping
other parts of his own body could also
be included
in the ability's definition of clapping
as well
regardless if you are up to date with
the manga though then you know that
he'll likely need to evolve this ability
and adapt it to his new situation
sure gojo is a super fun character to
watch because he's so cocky and
overpowered
but to me toto is just so much more
interesting he's funny
brings a lot of passion and energy into
the series and the dynamic that is this
big dumb muscle man who loves idols and
who is a supportive and philosophical
mentor is just
a really cool one to see and when you
add to that the fighting style that is
easily the most dynamic in the series
it makes him an easy favorite character
for me but what do you guys think of
toto let me know in the comments down
below
and also in the spirit of toto let me
know your taste in women in the comments
as well
or men or whatever else whatever floats
your boat don't worry
if you guys did enjoy this jiu-jitsu
kaizen video though and want to see more
please leave a like
and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
guarantee that you will not miss any
future videos
of course you can also follow anime
uproar on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt
uh is this something for anime uproar uh
yeah why
oh i just you know i just used to edit
almost every single video on the channel
for like over two years and like he made
me else
yeah i appreciate you quitting it's been
great for me uh yeah i i
speak of the witch i think you may send
a word in for me like to say hey you
know dakota said something about uh you
know editing or yeah yeah yeah
you know well we'll see i'll you know
i'll talk to him about it and just
tell him dakota said hi that he misses
them and they can unblock me on twitter
be great
um just kind of miss the uh appearances
and you know shout outs and whatnot
you know it's just kind of like weird to
talk to your boss about that sort of
thing you know it's really personal
yeah i know but like it needs to be my
boss first first of all you know i was
like i got
a job i got you a job so maybe you could
you know say hey say hey dakota you know
said hey
and maybe some work would be nice or
maybe appearances
and uh just tell them to go to so to say
hi or just tell dakota said
anything uh really hey i actually gotta
go i
i uh really thank you thank you so much
for your time i appreciate it uh tell
them to kind of miss them
i wanna give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a special thank you to the absolute mad
lad and disciple of lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and of course all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans ingrada pate heffa
algetal
dr cortman the toasted chi the spike
8227
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarcus
baked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kozitzki very gucci
alicia ochter
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia ted not ted
fatboy games corey mcgowan metal mama
deadly saint soul ride slice and dice if
you're enjoying our videos and feel like
they're adding some level of value to
your life please consider supporting us
over on patreon
even a dollar gives you access to our
patron exclusive discord
and we'll get your name in all of our
videos along with these fantastic
people thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
stay excellent
[Music]
uh is this something for anime uproar uh
yeah why
oh i just you know i just used to edit
almost every single video on their
channel for like over two years and
lucky maybe else
yeah i appreciate you quitting it's been
great for me uh yeah i i i
speaking of which i mean didn't you send
a word in for me like to say hey you
know dakota said something about uh you
know editing or yeah yeah yeah
you know well we'll see i'll you know
i'll talk to him about it
tell him dakota said hi that he misses
them and they can unblock me on twitter
be great
um just kind of miss the uh appearances
and you know shout outs and whatnot
you know it's just kind of like weird to
talk to your boss about that sort of
thing you know it's really personal
yeah i know but it needs to be my boss
first first of all you know i was like i
gotta
get a job i got you a job so maybe you
could you know say hey say hey dakota
you know said hey
and maybe some work would be nice or
maybe appearances
and uh just tell them to cut us so to
say hi
dakota said anything uh really hey i
actually gotta go
i i uh really thank you thank you so
much for your time i appreciate it uh
tell them to kind of miss them